yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Don Escobar sounds dangerous f
don't Escobar any additional information
there nope no name so we get the maracas
sea pines very light level okay he does
not have to take on the floor on the
next move and now you basically have to
let's see what we get 96 know this one
ok very ready treated tweenage five
that's a rare decision there we should
be 6f for this is a possible let's see
what does Escobar up to loop c8 and this
is hanging again from you have to go be
313 on a six i will go f5 this is repeat
interesting technical idea he cannot
take twice because before the end wins
the bishop so we have to move the bishop
back and now yeah I can play Bishop
takes f6 this is a possible line of
playing I practice on the board already
in and over the board chef and I think
it is dangerous black I think this was
what ahead on the porch I might be wrong
I might be wrong a little bit now that I
look at it this [ __ ] takes I wonder 95
Bishop g5 may be possible for black oh
it's possible I kind of wonder what he's
thinking about what context looks really
bad I mean maybe it's not terrible but
yeah yes I forgot about this friggin
Bishop g5 move now I still have to do it
I completely forgot that he has this
option okay so look look to c 3 is that
working look g3 coming e 6 53 little
shaky business all this shouldn't
Escobar be from Columbia instead it's
Ecuador yeah I was thinking this move
but maybe this isn't all that good okay
let's go go for it
you can take on d5 maybe I should've
taken once and this is an interesting
position though I mean I can take these
six is there anything particularly wrong
with that there is the check taking on
g6 you will take my book that's not
which again that's breakfast Quincy five
check Navy and that that could be an
idea well it looks like you should do
that actually okay yeah and now this
isn't all that great it's written in to
take on f5 with its look down hmm I clip
it uncomfortable okay I directly head
for the e3 square with the king
it's the right square anyway yeah yeah
at the end of the day these are
dangerous pause really on that was
really bad bad plane
and I look at some is misplaced rating
okay we are moving against roxio it
feels very wrong to me and because white
is just better but you can always
blunder like I did here catch it okay
yeah just too much unfortunately it's
also very easy to win yep quite a ways
yeah it was pretty bad and that line is
actually pretty awful food like he's the
thing so f 557 I just have to be more
alert here this is already pretty bad I
just played it too quickly I mean it
move like anything edge 1 also which is
good for white yeah I now threaten this
so I need to need to get out of a check
and then now I just played it too
quickly this is really a problem then I
in nineteen point and you have to take
now on g6 first and then you see three
and so dangerous they are dead she ever
26 first know that I didn't think of now
that is really awkward oh it's good i've
got before here in the skin
and this is handy and that's what's just
wrong I took on the six knowing that I'm
in trouble I should be just just I
should just try different stuff kind of
weird though that this is going to be
okay okay I'm double attacking a couple
of things here that's an extremely funky
line Wow yeah 40 and now now that
position just sucks yeah it just sucks
and I asked for swimming a piece already
yeah now that was bad i just played that
to superficially in the opening with
taking on f6 early on it was much better
to prepare the same just a bad idea yeah
here just the parrot is good stock which
wants to go a for that that make sense
queen bee three just prep move and then
then go for the strike in the center in
this position type even taking and
taking twice on f6 is interesting let's
say I go here and not sure what he does
let's say define you can you can even
consider to play this this is very
dangerous Oh Blackie I get to get a six
and i'm on the dark squares queen d 4
and so on it's a pretty dangerous
situation scope which immediately
recognizes the draw repeals but it's not
easy for back to play
sorry thank you for watching